il ya les manches et aller y est mis il
ya les sintis et il ya les gitans donc
on peut voir qu'on peut voir déjà que un
souci au niveau des des roms qui sont
illuminés pièces d'or a atteint 1 et
considérés comme des étrangers quand on
est là en france quoi c'est koné des
étrangers de france alors qu'ils sont de
15 août hadzic est rien et dîners
braccini malti sa manade nous appelons
tous canaris canaries c'est une fille
région qui travaillent ou sont entrés
dans la ville ils ont abattu mon frère
de sang froid dans ma tribu tard de
karima et l'entorse
coeur
et doucement tous les gitans du monde je
pense qu'on est les plus détestés de
toutes les autres communautés végétales
pour de vrai je pense qu'on devrait
encore papa le présent
bienvenue dans pôle it mag spécial
élections municipales les français ont
la parole pendant toute la campagne
on débat de vos préoccupations au
quotidien et parmi elles il y a bien sûr
le ras-le-bol fiscale et la dégradation
des services publics pourront parler
nous sommes avec alain mathieu président
de l'association des contribuables
associés
face à vous henri sterdyniak membres des
économistes atterrés et guillaume bigot
essayiste et directeur de l'ipag merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france les gilet jaune manifestent
depuis soixante cinq samedis consécutifs
en france un mouvement social inédit qui
a mis en lumière un malaise profond au
sein de la société une pression fiscale
jugée trop lourde par les ménages et une
dégradation des services publics
comment payer moins d'impôts et de taxes
tout en préservant les services de
proximité voyez là est la réponse du
premier ministre edouard philippe
c'était juste après le début de la crise
et gilet jaune nos impôts et taxes sont
les plus élevés d'europe
notre système fiscal est terriblement
complexe et il est souvent critiqué
parce qu'il serait injuste
discutons des modifications qu'il faut
lui apporter
et rappelons des règles claires d'abord
si les événements de ces derniers jours
ont démontré une chose c'est que les
français ne veulent ni hausse d'impôt ni
nouvelle taxe ensuite si les impôts
baissent il faudra que les dépenses
baissent car nous ne voulons pas léguer
des dettes à nos enfants
ces dettes sont déjà considérables 1
réaction guillaume bigot c'est avec
cette crise des gilets jaunes a mis en
lumière un dilemme payer moins d'impôts
tout en réhaussant en tout cas en
essayant de maintenir la qualité des
services publics en france c'est
vraiment laid gilet jaune qui ont révélé
ce ce dilemme non cette contradiction
elle existe depuis depuis longtemps mais
cette contradiction c'est celle dans
laquelle nous entraîne les choix de
politiques macroéconomiques
c'est à dire que quand vous contrôlez
plus votre monnaie et quand vous avez un
budget qui est contraint
justement par des règles qui sont qui
sont qui s'impose à vous en termes
d'endettement et quand vous ne pouvez
plus contrôler votre monnaie dont
pouvaient plus émettre de la monnaie
voulant emprunter sur des marchés
financiers vous avez une dette et cette
dette va s'accroître mécaniquement et
plus vous augmentez les impôts plus vous
contractez la colle finalement
l'activité économique
si vous contractez l'activité économique
pouvait moins remboursés donc vous avez
à chaque fois plus besoin d'emprunter
voilà on est rentrés dans une dynamique
de ce type et c'est cette contradiction
elle existe depuis longtemps donc on n'a
plus tellement de marge de manoeuvre
mais pour une raison assez paradoxale
qui froisse de sens commun c'est que
tant qu'on s'acharne à rembourser la
dette
tant qu'on fait du remboursement de la
dette le premier objectif voir la
première dépense publique
eh bien on aura plus jamais de marge de
manoeuvre
mais alors justement le gouvernement a
un petit peu fléchi sa politique en la
matière en lâchant du lest notamment on
l'a vu juste après cette crise des gilet
jaune 11 milliards d'euros injectés dans
l'économie baisse de la taxe
d'habitation il ya eu des mesures
incitatives
alain mathieu néanmoins les français ont
toujours le sentiment de payer trop
d'impôts aujourd'hui pourquoi nous
disons depuis trente ans que trop de
dépenses publiques c'est trop d'impôts
et je crois que les français ont fini
par le comprendre
même le premier ministre le disais tout
à l'heure c'est vrai si on avait moins
de dépenses publiques en aurait moins
d'impôts et donc à l'ars la dépensent
mix sont aussi les services publics
oui mais il y en a trop il ya trop de
dépenses dans les services publics aussi
alors donc il faudrait réduire le nombre
de fonctionnaires ça a été une promesse
aussi de la part de
des manuels macron henri sterdyniak on
le voit la promesse de diminuer les
fonctionnaires n'est pas tenue allait
même reléguée aux calendes grecques
aujourd'hui le gouvernement à changer de
politique
bon je sais pas s'il faut utiliser le
mot promesses mais c'est quand on
annonce aux gens quelque chose de
favorable ski 5,6 la promesse c'est de
dire il va y avoir moins d'infirmières
moins d'enseignants moins de policiers
moins de juges ont considéré que c'est
une promesse d' oncle je pense
qu'effectivement il ya tout un courant
une idéologie propagée par les libéraux
par les médias à 10 ans effectivement la
priorité c'est de réduire les dépenses
publiques et le nombre de fonctionnaires
mais en réalité lorsqu'on passe dans le
terrain s'aperçoit que c'est extrêmement
difficile et qui à chaque fois nasa se
heurte aux sentiments des gens les gens
lorsqu'ils vont à l'hôpital
ils veulent des médecins des infirmières
et collent pas mariner pendant voilà les
gens veulent des enseignants pour leur
fort quand l'enseignant est malade il
veut que l'enseignant soit remplacé les
gens veulent des bras puis en affaires
de mon afeas atome de choir un tiers par
exemple militaire là et drôle que c'est
très dur c'est très dur de réduire enfin
on peut toujours le dire on va réduire
le nombre de fonctionnaires mais dans la
réalité ça marche pas quoi donc c'est
que macron s'est trouvé confronté au
réel quoi c'est pour ça qu'il a été
amené à changer un peu sa stratégie soit
il a changé un peu sa stratégie normand
on le voit dans la rue en les infirmiers
les pompiers les policiers sont toujours
mécontents de leur sort guillaume bigot
qu'est ce que ça montre aujourd'hui vous
disiez ça fait longtemps que ça existe
mécontentement entre payer trop d'impôts
mais là pour le coup c'est quand même
assez exacerbée c'est à dire que le la
question c'est qu'effectivement il ya on
sait bien qu'un bon impôt c'est un impôt
qui a une assiette large et un taux
relativement bas
là où on peut considérer jeu j'abonde
dans le sens de sio sterdyniak je
pensais beaucoup d'idéologie derrière la
question du taux de prélèvements
obligatoires et la question de savoir si
une dépense publique ou une dépense
privée
prendre un exemple simple sont les
dépenses de santé en france les dépenses
de santé représentent 11% du pib aux
etats unis 17 % du pib' qu'on dépense de
la santé de manière privée le cours de
bourse de la santé de manière publique
la question n'est pas de savoir si on en
dépense d'abord pour en dépenser moins
manifestement il vaut mieux dépenser de
la santé publique que de la santé privée
toutes choses égales par ailleurs
et deuxièmement il faut savoir qui à
l'espérance de vie la plus la plus
longue et qui est le mieux traité est ce
qu est ce qu est un citoyen américain
pousse un citoyen français
donc ça lui en économie il faut avoir
une approche toujours extrêmement
pragmatique et ne pas faire d'idéologie
or effectivement il ya eu l'idéologie
communiste maintenant il ya l'idéologie
libérale et c'est la même chose c'est à
dire qu' on ne peut absolument pas avoir
une analyse une offre une approche
pragmatique d'aider des faits sans
complexe et ses oeillères idéologiques
dessus maintenant ceci étant dit il faut
considérer quand même que la la la
fiscalité ne peut pas augmenter les
arbres montent pas jusqu'au ciel aucun
moment c'est effectivement ça peut
étouffer l'activité économique ça c'est
bien certain
la question est plutôt maintenant de
savoie et les français sont dans cette
optique je pense de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on encaisse qu'on a pour notre argent
à la saisie effectivement on en a pas
assez pour notre argent
mais là aussi il faut gratter parce que
lorsque vous mettez des services publics
à loos lorsque vous n'investissez plus
les tgv les infrastructures fera sur
thur les autres gâteaux etc
vous avez un service public qui va se
dégrader et donc là vous avez un
argument massue pour dire ben écoutez ça
ne fonctionne pas donc on va le lâcher
ou servi au secteur privé et on revient
sur des facteurs sur des coups sûrs des
sur des sorts des facteurs idéologiques
alors je pas tomber dans ce que je dis
non je dis pas que le privé est
nécessairement plus mauvais plus coûteux
moins efficace que le public sait pas ça
la question
je dis simplement que il faut regarder
dans ses dépenses publiques ce qui
relève de la gabegie
il me semble que la décentralisation
sénégal j par exemple on pourra en
reparler
parce qu'on nous parle d'économie
d'échelle ça c'est un grand argument des
libéraux pour dire il faut par exemple
que les entreprises fusionnent quand
elle fusionne elles ont des économies
d'échelle
alors si c'est vrai pour les entreprises
privées pourquoi serait pas vrai pour
les dépenses publiques pourquoi éclater
les dépenses publiques dans les
collectivités locales
est ce que c'est le alors à l'armature
voulu réagir est ce que disait monsieur
guillaume bigot
non je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
lui il faut être pragmatique pragmatique
ça veut dire notamment faire des
comparaisons avec l'étranger et la
comparaison qui tombe sous le sens
les français c'est la comparaison avec
l'allemagne et quand on fait la
comparaison avec l'allemagne qu'est ce
qu'on constate on constate que les
allemands ont 4 millions 600 mille
fonctionnaires
nous on en a 7 millions 7 millions c'est
un population égale ça veut dire qu'on a
trois millions quatre cent mille
fonctionnaires de trop par rapport aux
allemands alors comment ça s'explique en
partie par le temps de travail qui n'est
pas le même puisque nous on n'arrive pas
à les faire faire 35 heures en
fonctionnaires et à l'absentéisme qui
est beaucoup plus important qu'en
allemagne
ils partent à la retraite trois ans plus
tôt que les allemands donc il ya des
raisons dans la durée de travail dans
une vie est de l'ordre de 30% en moins
par rapport à fonctionnaires à le voir
d'autres gens c'est une partie de
l'explication mais ce n'est pas tout de
l'explication
il ya aussi le fait que ces bals
organisés en france il ya des
fonctionnaires qui font de la paperasse
et qui ne font que de la paperasse
l'époque des juges n'y a pas que les
fonctionnaires
il ya énormément de fonctionnaires qui
ne font que la paperasse
il ya aussi des fonctionnaires qui ne
servent à rien et à 256 956pts sous
préfecture sans précédent un plaqueur
qui ne servent à rien c'est un
empilement de tâches de double otages
finalement qui pourrait il accomplit par
par mois une fonctionnaire c'est ça
votre raisonnement bien sûr on pourrait
les allemands n'ont pas de service
public inférieur au nôtre mais ils ont
la moitié de fonctionnaires par rapport
à l'état des routes en allemagne honorer
l exilé à paris moi allez je vous dis
allez les voir à paris c'est vraiment
pas brillant à lèvres à paris alors on
faisait le séduit on va le voir sur
cette carte qui ressort en clair vous
allez le voir les zones de désert
médical en france le centre val de loire
et particulièrement touchés par cette
pénurie de services médicaux nos
reporters nadège ad razak éducateurs
sont allés recueillir les témoignages de
ces personnes qui vivent loin de tout
service public regardez c'est vrai que
c'est difficile pour les genres euros
c'est ce que je dis toujours vous ne
vous ne pouvez pas vous déplacer dans
les villes ils ont tout ce qu'il faut
ils ont les bus
ce ils ont tous à proximité nous on est
les derniers roue de la charrette temps
nous nous les gens de la campagne oui on
est des gens à part on a le droit à rien
on n'a pas le droit d'aller prendre le
train on n'a pas de gars je crois pas
non il n'est pas hors visualisons diesel
disons tous non je vois que l'on attend
tandis que c'est pour se faire soigner
moi je vais avant j'allais attendre
qu'ils la mettent ici les partis à la
retraite aussi et là maintenant je vais
à john j'en ai trouvé un jaune une sécu
mais pourquoi pas un jeune médecin le
maître pendant quatre ou cinq ans il ya
posé une région au bout de quatre ou
cinq ans après choisir où ils veulent
comme ça il y aurait jamais eu de
pénurie de médecins dans une région
après je sais pas si c'est faisable pas
faisable
ça pourrait être une solution dans
l'éducation nationale
au bout de temps l'année après ils ont
droit de choisir où ils veulent aller et
voilà dans le centre val de loire 56%
des personnes jugent l'impôt utile mais
70% pensent ne pas en bénéficier on le
voit henri sterdyniak
cette dégradation des services publics
ça remonte à quand exactement et est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un problème en
france ils sont il ya le sentiment
depuis une vingtaine d'années mais c'est
lié effectivement au fait que la
ruralité c'est changer de nature que des
personnes qui vivaient tout à fait
naturellement à la campagne où il était
habitué à ce mode de vie lorsque des
citadins viennent s'y installer
naturellement c'est un choc ses
différentes missions humaines qui a fait
au ccc bon ben c'est une c'est une vie
différente voilà mais par ailleurs
effectivement le problème que l'état a
décidé de faire des économies donc on a
fermé des classes rurales on a fermé des
services de l'état
il faut des hauts niveaux niveaux bureau
et puis le fait elle que les libéraux
les médecins kinésithérapeutes a envie
d'aller s'installer dans des zones où
naturellement le revenu est plus faible
et les conditions de travail sont plus
difficiles donc c'est pas seulement une
question de service public c'est
également une question quotidienne de
vie quotidienne c'est pareil à la limite
quand vous êtes dans tel ou tel village
de bretagne vous avez peut-être pas des
services publics
c'est pas non plus la banque parce que
la banque est la plus belle a pas envie
d'avoir une agence dans un endroit où
effectivement il ya ya ya ya pas
demandant que la solution comme on la
libye c'est une solution coûteuse à côté
en même temps là qu'il faut penser de
dire ben voilà on rétablit des
dispensaires ruraux
on propose à des médecins effectivement
d'aller travailler dans ces dispensaires
en même temps ça pose la question que
notre société et pas simplement sk pas
simplement le problème des services
publics et le problème de la croissance
des inégalités de de revenus qui change
également
il ya un tifo les inégalités de revenus
qui font que les médecins préfèrent
s'installer dans des villes dans des
quartiers prospères où il espère
effectivement avoir des revenus
importants plus tôt que à la campagne
oui où
naturellement ils ont pas les mêmes les
mêmes revenus donc ça pose aussi cette
question alors vous parliez des services
privés comme les banques là on parle de
service public il ya une mission de
service public néanmoins est ce que le
fait d'avoir voulu rentabiliser
et ces services publics finalement n'a
pas scellé leur sort
guillaume bigot oui c'est un c'est un
paradoxe parce que souvent en matière de
comportement économique et c'est vrai
pour un état même dans une entreprise
d'ailleurs soit vous avez une stratégie
dynamique soit vous avez une stratégie
d'investissement ça ne veut pas dire que
vous dépenser sans compter
mais globalement vous tablez sur
l'avenir et vous investissez soit vous
avez une politique de freinage de
maîtrise des coûts et à force de vouloir
maîtriser beaucoup en fait vous
enclenchez un phénomène de
ralentissement naturel qui fait que vous
avez moins de rentrées finalement alors
vous freiner les charges fermé mais vous
freiner les produits et aussi donc ce
qui est vrai un peu vrai dans le secteur
privé
et ô combien vrai dans le secteur public
puisque en fait les impôts plus vous
avez finalement de croissance économique
prenons un exemple plus les gens
travaillent moins on va les payer en
tant que chômeurs et plus le travail
plus ils vont faire rentrer les
cotisations sociales
vous voyez bien que si vous avez une
action qui vise à maîtriser les charges
à réduire les charges
toutes choses égales par ailleurs vous
allait ralentir l'activité économique et
si vous ralentissez l'activité
économique
mécaniquement vous allez faire déraper
les finances publiques ça c'est un
facteur clé que les fanatiques du
libéralisme ne rappelle jamais mais
pourtant c'est une réalité qui est tout
à fait mesurable sur la question des
campagnes vous aviez vous avez raison il
ya une il y à une désertification mais
il n'ya pas que l'ex il ya cette
approche gestionnaire de l'état qu'elle
joue un rôle c'est sûr maintenant on ne
peut pas gelé d'une certaine façon
l'activité économique on ne peut pas
empêcher les facteurs de production de
se déplacer des régions d'être plus
dynamiques que d'autres
le progrès technique enfin si on regarde
en départements comme le lot par exemple
il y avait une population extrêmement
dense au début du 20e siècle et du
phosphate il y avait du tabac cette
activité a périclité et voilà c'est
l'activité économique naturel
en revanche ce qui est frappant c'est de
voir que cette solidarité on la joue à
l'échelle de l'europe alors par exemple
on dit oui mais l'europe on paye presque
j'ai passé 60 milliards les
collectivités locales et l'union
européenne sur le budget de l'état ce
qui est considérable quand même faut
réduire les inégalités et on est en fait
on ne récupère une partie c'est vrai
avec les fonds européen pour
l'agriculture mais globalement la
contribution nette de la france et de 11
milliards
alors je peux vous assurer que si on
avait 11 milliards injectés dans nos
collectivités plutôt que de payer des
routes aux portugais
la grèce ça serait pas la même chose ça
c'est faire partie de l'europe ou pas
que cette idéologie à nouveau par contre
le fait que la france soit championne
d'europe des de la pression fiscale
c'est vrai qu'on est numéro un en
matière d'impôts pourtant les services
publics ne cessent de se dégrader
pourquoi puisqu'on fait de plus en plus
d'impôts mais les services publics ne
suivent pas
car hélas quelle est la raison et à
mathieu selon vous je voulais
fonctionnaire n'a pas forcément augmenté
ces dernières années
je sais pas si j'ai la banque vous avez
votre question mais je voulais souligner
que dans le coût d'un service public
il ya un problème d'organisation qui
compte beaucoup si on est plus ou moins
bien organisée si on compare par exemple
pour l'enseignement secondaire
le coût par élève dans le secteur public
il est 2 4924 euros par élève parent
c'est 55 % de plus que dans le secteur
privé
comment ça c'est fait alors je vais vous
expliquer je vais vous expliquer et
injustement parle d'organisation mais
aussi de d'affectation des gens ils ont
plus d'engagés qui coûte plus cher mais
son prix du pétrole qui sont mieux à
utiliser mais il coûte plus cher ils ont
moins de contractuels qui coûte aussi
moins cher dans le secteur privé sont
moins d'absentéisme dans le secteur
privé que dans le secteur public
nettement mois ils ont donc un certain
nombre de facteurs d'organisation je
dirais qu'ils font que le secteur public
coûte 55 % plus cher que le secteur
privé l'ordre je viens mais enfin vous
savez il est très simple de coûter moins
cher
je veux dire à partir du moment où on
remplace du personnel qualifié par des
gens qu'on ne paye pas des gens à statut
précaire effectivement ça coûte beaucoup
moins cher
regardez regardez par exemple des dix
métiers comme gardien de musée avant il
y avait des gens compétents
voilà des tests est une profession les
gens devenaient des gardiens de musée
l'iran qui renseignait les gens voilà
maintenant ça n'existe plus qu'est ce
qu'on fait reprend des sociétés privées
qui eux mêmes utilisent des gens qui
sont payés au smic ça on est capable de
le faire
je veux dire le sarrau ça on sait faire
de le problème le problème c'est que le
la caractéristique du secteur public
jusqu'à présent c'était de garantir une
certaine égalité des traitements les
inégalités de traitement était beaucoup
plus faible
il y avait la grille de la fonction
publique or lorsque on privatise d'une
façon ou d'une autre lorsqu'on fait des
agences effectivement on détruit ce
phénomène on a d'un côté les cadres
supérieurs qui ont des salaires
exorbitants
allez les gens qui dirigent les agences
dont des salaires exorbitants pour rien
à voir avec la grille de la fonction
publique et de l'autre et là on va faire
des économies c'est à dire qu'on va
embaucher effectivement sous sous cdd
des contrats précaires des gens qui vont
pas avoir la sécurité de l'emploi voilà
c'est c'est c'est destructeur pour notre
temps pour la cohésion sociale
d'autre part en ce qui concerne le taux
de prélèvements obligatoires
il faut savoir que ce qui différencie la
france des autres pays c'est avant tout
avant tout nos dépenses de protection
sociale c'est avant tout nos dépenses de
retraite est populaire c'est le fait que
en france
les retraités ont le même niveau de vie
que les actifs alors qu'en suède
ils ont un niveau de vie plus bas de 25
% en allemagne de 20% il ya un certain
nombre de ses pas c'est c'est pas des
services sont riches mais c'est quand
même extrêmement loin des choix de
l'hôtel demain il faut dire aussi
en france on a conservé deux enfants par
femme à peu près en allemagne sont 1,3
ça permet quand même quand même lâché
1,2 vois moi virus 1,3 enfant par femme
le mandat dans les talibans de
l'allemagne ça permet quand même en
moyenne ça permet quand même de faire
des économies sur l'américaine à permet
quand même de faire des économies sur
l'éducation s'est traduit si c'est
l'association espère m oment en matière
d'allocations familiales à bombay mario
dion c'est vous dire via les ya des tas
régime militaire en france ou si c'est
un vin
neuf enfants par femme en allemagne
alain mathieu jeudi avec l'audition
alors oui ce que je voulais dire c'est
que quand je reprends ma comparaison
entre dans le secondaire entre le privé
et le public
personne aucun de téléspectateurs à mon
avis ne dira le secteur privé est mal
gérée il fonctionne mal au contraire
vous avez de nombreux fonctionnaires qui
mettent leurs enfants dans le secteur
privé de l'éducation
donc il fonctionne pas mal alors il
simplement c'est une question
d'organisation s'est massivement payés
par les impôts je veux dire le secteur
privé on lui on lui directs auxquels le
serveur arrive et il est payée par des
impôts
voilà c'est tout et en plus il fait de
la sélection plus vif est de la
sélection parmi ses élèves
ce que ne peut pas permettre le secteur
public quand on a 15 ans et ensuite vos
chiffres sont tout à fait farfelu
parce que vous oubliez que toute
l'organisation effectivement elle repose
sur le public à ces chiffres sont
officiels qui est ce qu'ils payent
l'éducation le noeud
l'enseignement privé c'est les impôts
oui mais aussi le voir avec son salaire
payée par les banques privées publiques
dans l'enseignement c'est vrai que dans
le privé c'est sous contrat c'est donc
avec les mêmes contraintes que dans le
secteur public n'est pas de différence
ils ont les mêmes diplômes et georges
que vous connaissez déjà dans
l'enseignement secondaire perret pour le
pot le contribuable ça coûte beaucoup
moins cher
je vous dis 55 % exactement lorsque le
support que vous connaissez un peu
l'enseignement secondaire privée vous
rendez compte
de quoi vous rendez compte qu'il ya une
fuite d des classes moyennes supérieures
et des classes supérieures vers
l'enseignement privé massive donc vous
concentrer les bons élèves de recettes
privées ne peuvent pas exactement et
vous avez de mauvais profs
voilà mais ça donne mais bien sûr que
s'il est toute chose un cadre agréable
on met les gens mais ce que vous aviez
en majorité des profs commun donc il
s'agit en fait dont les profs sont
meilleurs professeurs car moi j'ai un
enfant qui est en cours dans le privé
dans l'info qui l'ont public nous dire
que dans le public
les profs sont meilleurs mais les élèves
ont moins voyagé pour plus il ya plus
c'est bien ce midi mais non mais en
revanche je sais ça veut dire que ça
descende rire il y à des dîners sûr
parce que la question centrale se pose
est noté sur les français c'est de
savoir si on en a pour son argent avec
des prélèvements obligatoires
relativement élevé est de plus en plus
on est conduit à dire et entend bien
même on serait plutôt à partie dans ce
qui est mon cas du service public
on est conduit à dire non mais si on dit
non c'est pas parce que il ya un niveau
trop élevé des dépenses là
nécessairement une gabegie
il y à des choix là ce sont les sous
jacents prenons l'exemple de l'éducation
c'est typique si vous démolissez les
programmes scolaires
si vous faites du
je lui dise ou du massacre de programmes
scolaires si vous transformez les clés
classement garderie si vous faites venir
massivement d'immigration je suis pas
contre l'immigration j'ai simplement que
pour que l'immigration fonctionne il
faut créer une grande quantité d'enfants
du coin d'enfants indigènes et une
petite minorité d'enfants immigrés dans
les classes quand vous avez cette mixité
il peut y avoir une assimilation
si vous avez des classes avec une
concentration des enfants immigrés comme
les gens du pays maintenant sortent
leurs enfants et les mettre dans le
privé vous aggraver cette situation plus
d'aider des programmes absolument pour y
ait en fait vous dites ça ne marche pas
si loin que ça va pas nécessairement de
rapport avec le niveau de dépenses
publiques c'est une question politique
restez avec nous on continue ce débat
sur ce ras-le-bol fiscale dénoncée
notamment par cette crise des gilet
jaune le gouvernement qui a tenté
d'apporter des réponses à ces
revendications mais qui n'a pas vraiment
réussi à inverser la tendance en tout
cas sur ce malaise social actuel en
france on en parle dans quelques minutes
à tout de suite
[Musique]
il faut bien comprendre que les champs
de schiste pétroliers américains donc
quelques temps vont s'arrêter de
produire violer toutes les données
pétrolières sont confidentielles
est ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'à terme
avec le pétrole de schiste les
américains soient énergétique
indépendant banon ils sont en train de
frôler indépendance mais pour le pour le
gars cylisme en mai pour le pétrole
non c'est puis là le puil gist sont des
puits qui donne le maximum
les premiers mois après c'est une chute
continuelle et si le pétrole de schiste
des cent cette année
suffisamment pour que ça soit notable en
moins devant brême ne sera pareil
je
à
ou est-ce qu'on en est au niveau de la
radicalisation dans les sports que le
terme radicalisation c'est un peu un mot
valise et ont même beaucoup de choses
qui ne reflète pas la réalité dans part
de la radicalisation islamiste dans le
sport c'est tout ce processus qui peut
conduire quelqu'un à se mettre en marge
totale de la société parfois même
basculer vers l'action violente en 2016
au moins sportifs considèrent que
c'était pas son affaire et qu'il n'avait
pas être une sorte de délateurs des
pouvoirs publics ce que le sujet c'est
qu'aujourd'hui toute une série de
phénomènes nous échappe
ce sont ces associations qui se créent
ou bien des structures qui se créent en
dehors du mouvement organisé certains
ont dit le sport amateur c'est le
premier lieu vecteur de radicalisation
c'est faux c'est la prison dans les
clubs
il peut y avoir des cas de prosélytisme
mais pas contre les radicaliser ne vont
que à la mosquée ne sont plus à l'école
ne sont plus dans les clubs
retirez vos de la tête que le sport
associatif
pollitt mag la suite avec alain mathieu
président de l'association des
contribuables associés henri sterdyniak
membres des économistes atterrés et
guillaume bigot essayiste et directeur
de l'ipag depuis la crise des gilets
jaunes donc les français dénonce la
pression fiscale et la détérioration des
services publics
à quoi servent les impôts et comment
sont-ils dépensés par l'état
éléments de réponse avec notre
journaliste ben hassen chebbi et on en
parle bien sûr après avec nos invités
291 3 milliards d'euros c'est ce que
l'état a récolté l'an dernier tout
impôts confondus
parmi les contribuables les entreprises
et les citoyens français mais pas tous
moins de la moitié des foyers de
l'hexagone sont imposables
vous pouvez payer deux sortes d'impôts
l'impôt direct qui inclut la taxe sur la
valeur ajoutée ou tva et bien sûr
l'impôt indirect incluant notamment
l'impôt sur le revenu la france est
championne du monde en matière de
prélèvements obligatoires mais également
en matière de dépenses publiques pour
exemple sur 100 euros d'impôts elle est
obligée d'emprunter 5 euros à l'union
européenne
et ce sans parler des intérêts mais
alors que fait l'état de notre argent
sur cette base de 100 euros 55 sont
consacrés à financer les retraites la
santé ou encore la sécurité sociale et
l'éducation soit plus de la moitié de
cette somme le reste eh bien il est
réparti entre la défense la justice ou
encore les infrastructures est loin
derrière on retrouve les secteurs tels
que la culture le logement ou encore la
transition écologique
la question de l'impôt sur le revenu
cristallise les tensions sociales et on
a pu le voir avec la crise des gilets
jaunes en dix ans son montant a augmenté
de 54% et vu la dégradation des services
publics en france
les contribuables n'ont vraiment pas
l'impression d'en avoir pour leur argent
voilà un an et sterdyniak on l'a vu pour
100 euros finalement d'impôts il faut
néanmoins emprunter encore 5 euros
supplémentaires à l'union européenne
ben je sais pas ça je suis pas au
courant je ne pense pas que la france
emprunte cette union européenne je vois
pas pourquoi la france empruntera
l'ignorent
la france emprunte effectivement elle
emprunte aux marchés financiers on a un
déficit d'un fils vit au dessus de ses
moyens non madame
on emprunte environ 2 % de notre pib aux
marchés financiers
voilà c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
énorme
en même temps on leur rembourse 2% notre
pub en charles d'intérêt donc grosso
modo on on est on est équilibré on vit
pas au dessus de nos moyens on emprunte
9% du pib par an non non non non oui
mais c'est le problème c'est que ces
frais de gestion mais ça sert à
rembourser d'autres emprunts en aide en
est actuellement on emprunte 2% du pib
et charge d'intérêts de deux manches à
rien de neuf pour seulement on emprunte
on emprunte autant prat mais
effectivement une grande partie une
grande partie de la dette tourne plus
c'est à dire que est-ce que
naturellement on trouve des emprunteurs
aidés pour trouver des prêteurs c'est
pas un problème alors c'est toujours
l'argument qui est brandi en ce
remboursement de cette dette colossale
de la france est ce que c'est un réel
problème finalement pour pour un état
comme la france d'avoir une dette
colossale est ce qu'il faut absolument
rembourser quitte à voir des politiques
de restriction de rigueur en tout cas
mais là c'est pas seulement un constat
économique c'est un constat presque
historique c'est systématiquement les
états qui tiennent les banques sont
jamais les banques qui tiennent les
états les acteurs financiers rixe même
des banques gigantesque énormèment des
grandes institutions financières sont
incapables de fonctionner sans les états
et on l'a vu pendant la crise de 2008
sont toujours les états qui remettent au
pot
ce sont les prêteurs en dernier ressort
les états il faut imaginer que s'il n'y
a pas d'ordre public s'il n'y a pas de
tribunaux s'il n'y a pas pu sauver la
monnaie c'est une sur deux c'est une
sorte de confiance cristallisé et donc
ce qui garantit cette confiance c'est
des gens qui sont capables de faire
appliquer l'ordre et garantir des
contrats donc ce sont les états donc si
vous voulez ça n'a absolument aucun sens
d'affoler sans arrêt la population sur
le thème de les marchés financiers nous
tienne
nous étrangle et c'est en fait
simplement sur des choix politiques
macroéconomiques considérons qu'il faut
à tout prix rembourser la dette
et comme je vous l'indiquais tout à
l'heure plus on essaye de le rembourser
finalement moins y arrive et je vous
rassure jusqu'à présent n'a jamais
remboursé la dette jamais je veux dire à
la jeune homme depuis quelques années la
france déficit et donc on ne rembourse
pas la dette
chaque année l'actuellement 7,9 à 2020
normalement c'est la première année où
on sera équilibré c'est à dire que le
montant du déficit ne correspondra que
aux charges d'intérêts mais depuis de
longues années vingtaine d'années on
accumule de la dette ont la rembourse
jamais et aux larves et ce qu'il faut
voir aussi c'est que la dette est
détenue en fait l'équivalent de la dette
est détenue en fait part des français
par l'assurance vie grosso modo
l'assurance vie ça équivaut à la dette
donc on a un certain nombre de personnes
tout à faire des français qui ont 50 ans
60 ans ils se disent il faut que quand
même que j'ai de l'assurance vie comme
ça si j'ai un problème je serai pas la
charge de maisons fort et ces gens là
ils prêtent à l'état
assurance vie et voilà c'est pas la
dette publique elle est désirée la
preuve c'est qu'on la place aujourd'hui
à des taux négatifs il ya des gens qui
sont tout à fait content de détenir
l'assurance vie c'est principalement des
français ou à la limite des fonds de
pension étrangers pour la première fois
depuis dix ans elle a la pression
fiscale a a diminué pour les ménages
mais ça a touché et ça a bénéficié
davantage aux actifs qu'aux retraités ou
aux chômeurs avec 5 % des ménages les
plus aisés qui ont profité de cette
baisse de la pression fiscale réaction à
la mathieu les
les plus défavorisés finalement ne s'y
retrouvent pas dans cette politique de
baisse des impôts du du gouvernement
aujourd'hui 1
actuellement il ya d'abord il n'ya
pratiquement pas de baisse des impôts
enfin très peu c'est minime quand on
compare à voir une augmentation de la
taxe d'habitation au nom le nom
comparaison ce café trump aux etats unis
ils abaisser le taux de l'impôt sur les
sociétés de 35 21
parce que tu as tu pris il a supprimé
tous les droits de succession jusqu'à 10
millions de dollars
il a réduit le taux maximum de l'impôt
selon l'onu cette baisse va si massive
alors quand on fait des baisses massives
de pascal un taux de chômage aussi qu'il
est ridicule
bien sûr on a envie car vous faites des
baisses massives ça se voit parce que il
ya une expansion qui arrivent ils sont à
3% de d'expansion nous on est à 1 % peu
près donc il est certain que quand on
baisse les impôts c'est vrai dans tout
le pays
kennedy l'avait fait aussi reagan l'a
vérifié on avait fait aussi il y avait
baissé les impôts et du coup c'était
reparti il avait diminué le nombre de
fonctionnaires de 500 milles et il y
avait eu un million cinq cent mille
oeufs emplois nouveaux dans le secteur
privé donc il est certain que quand on
baisse les impôts ça se voit ça augmente
ça augmente même les recettes fiscales
parce que il se trouve qu aux etats unis
bien qu'ils aient baissé massivement les
taux des impôts ils ont plus de recettes
fiscales en 2018 qui donne en 2015 5% de
plus israël parce que utile valletta
nous permet d'avoir un déficit public de
7% du pib' fils disparu mais c'est
complètement faux oui ils sont à quatre
pour cent quand on a un déficit public
de 7% du pib là on peut se permettre
effectivement mois dans la peau d'un
effet de vérifier vos chiffres et deux
lettres parce que l'appareil à vérifier
mais si on perd il faut baisser encore
plus les impôts j'aurais bien sûr je
dois retrouver la compétition bien sûr
surtout sur les entreprises parce que
c'est les entreprises quand on compare
l'allemagne elles sont minimes 1 la
charge les charges des entreprises
aujourd'hui comparé à l'os et aux pays
de l'union européenne
alors elles ne sont pas énormes iliad 9%
du pib de différence avec l'allemagne
c'est énorme c'est 200 milliards de 100
milliards de différence
enfin impôts et cotisations sociales
patronales
si on prend les deux il ya 3 % du pib de
différence avec l'allemagne pour les
impôts il ya 6 % pour les cotisations
patronales c'est énorme comme différence
et c'est une des explications de la
stagnation française parce que la france
stagne depuis des années depuis 15 ans
l'allemagne se croient plus que la
france pourquoi parce que nous avons
plus de charges sur les entreprises
puisque nous n'avons qui les allemands
d'entreprises allemandes non non c'est
aussi simple que ça si vous baisser les
charges sur les entreprises
vous aurez une expansion peut-être pas
autant que les états unis on verra mais
enfin on y arrivera peut-être investi au
toc l'allemagne l'allemagne est une
catastrophe à l'union à l'échelle de
l'union européenne effectue mort que
l'allemand accumule des excédents qui
déséquilibre complètement l'union
européenne non est-ce que c'est une
réelle est ce que c'est une heure est ce
que c'est un bon résultat sur le plan
social
une notation de la pauvreté les
retraités sont d'abord raté et ella bleu
et tout le monde
par ailleurs l'allemagne est soumis elle
croit plus à trouver d'accord sur
l'allemagne
d'accord la journée quand cette année
par exemple elle va faire j'ai eu
l'année dernière elle a fait 0 4% de
croissance de [ __ ] ça pour quoi
deux buteurs zalman l'allemagne as une
stratégie qu'il a fait il a qui fait
qu'elle est soumise en permanence à tous
les chocs de l'économie mondiale elle
accumule des excédents résultat à kiev
attaqué acquis peut-elle prêter ses
excédents obligatoirement à des pays
fragiles donc elle a prêté ses excédents
à à la grèce ensuite bon voilà ça fait
ça fait le havre l almanach est passé de
chômage de 9 ans elle croit d'à peu près
depuis quinze ans de 1% par an de plus
elle marche beaucoup mieux que la france
personne ne peut dire quand le niveau de
vie allemands qui étaient également
français quinze ans maintenant il est
20% supérieur une différence dit en
français vous aurez 20% plus si on fait
comme l'allemagne
peut-être que
parler des travailleurs pauvres
aujourd'hui les pauvres ont le sentiment
de devenir encore plus pauvres guillaume
bigot lallaing la baisse d'impôts en
tout cas des incitations du gouvernement
sont plutôt en faveur des classes
moyennes c'est c'est quoi c'est inciter
les classes qui travaillent aujourd'hui
les français qui travaillent et qui
veillent donc des impôts
enfin les principales baisses d'impôts
ont concerné quand même elles ont
démarré au début du quinquennat
d'emmanuel bacon ont concerné quand même
l'impôt sur la fortune
mais bien sûr donc ça ç'a eu
relativement peu d'effet d'une part
d'autres dispositifs de type mac et
mesurer l'appétit d'un port au pardon
les retombées dans celle ci on améliorer
sans même leur retour le retour des
exilés fiscaux
donc ça a été ça c'est ça c'est ça a
baissé de 25% à peu près autour des
baisers des exilés fiscaux ils sont pas
ils sont pas revenus massivement fabien
de moins que son parti y en a moins 25%
de moins qu'ils allaient partie mais ça
mais ils doivent continuer quand même à
partir mais en moins pourquoi un rythme
moins important
en fait cette mélissa faisait pas été
supprimée vous le savez bien c'est lui
remplace bien sûr il a été remplacé
c'est un peu moins de cadeaux pour les
pour les gens avaient supprimé y en aura
encore à sa mise à l'eau pour lille pour
ceux qui sont les plus imposés en france
enfin des dispositifs type le crédit
crédit d'impôt pour les entreprises a eu
relativement peu d'effet et peu d'impact
en termes de création d'emplois donc je
peux enfin l'effet prix dont parle mon
voisin avec une baisse de charge une
baisse d'impôts ça améliorerait la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
moi je veux bien mais il y aura un effet
plus massive parce que c'était bien
entendu il ya un effet beaucoup plus
massif que ça on pourra obtenir le même
résultat si vous jouez sur la monnaie et
là on en revient effectivement on au
coup de main au coût de passe passe au
tour de passe passe assez sournois que
nous joue l'allemagne depuis qu'il ya
l'euro puisque grâce à l'euro en fait il
faut bien comprendre que l'allemagne qui
aura une monnaie beaucoup plus forte il
y avait encore à deutsche mark
amorti la hausse de sa monnaie sur les
économies à faible productivité
donc c'est un coup de chômeurs allemands
et grecs pardon français et grec que les
allemands peuvent avoir une monnaie
relativement compétitifs grâce à nous
heureusement ceaurriz voilà les
excédents faire tourner la planche à
billets je vois que ça vaut mieux
ah bon pourquoi ça va bien
parce que c'est le rôle on n'aurait pas
de sens économique non j'en ai pas du
tout fiscalité le effectivement le
gouvernement a commencé par donner 5
milliards aux plus riches en sucre en
baissant l'usf et en mettant le pays fut
donc une baisse importante de la de la
fiscalité sur les revenus du capital
totalement injustifiée 5 milliards aux
plus riches
ensuite malheureusement pour des raisons
démagogiques le gouvernement à baisser
la taxe d'habitation de 10 milliards
mais ça profite aux classes moyennes
parce que les pauvres déjà ne paient pas
de taxe d'habitation et le problème
c'est qui va encore baisser
savard baissé de 10 milliards la taxe
d'habitation et ce coup-ci uniquement
pour les plus riches donc donc c'est pas
c'est pas ça n'a pas été un choix génial
et le gouvernement qui n'est pas donc ça
profite aux plus aisés ça a profité aux
plus aisés en même temps en même temps
il ya eu des mesures de réductions des
allocations logement il ya eu des
mesures de baisse des allocations
chômage qui ont il ya eu et qui ont nui
aux plus pauvres est par ailleurs le
gouvernement est persuadé que les
retraités sont trop riches et docks
il a remonté la csg sur les retraités il
a désindexé les retraités au profit des
actifs et donc on a une une politique
qui a augmenté les revenus des actifs au
détriment des retraites pas au détriment
des retraités mais ça c'est un choix
politique assumé par le gouvernement et
les français qui se demandent qui paye
finalement les ampoules les revenus du
travail ou les revenus du capital les
ménages ou les entreprises
pour l'essentiel les ménages la première
source de revenus pour l'état c'est la
tva sont les impôts indirects ce que ce
cas là j ai gens devraient voir impôts
d'ailleurs totalement injuste puisqu'il
est absolument pas progressé d'où soyez
riche ou pauvre alors modulo la tva sur
les produits de luxe effectivement
n'existe plus bon alors merci en plus ce
qui nous divise
je ne demande la suppression justement
de la tva sur les produits de première
nécessité et là non plus nous voulions
n'a pas suivi pourquoi le gouvernement
n'a pas suivi pour une raison simple
en france on a beaucoup de d'impôts mais
il ya trois impôt qui rapporte beaucoup
la tva la csg et les cotisations
sociales est folle et le gouvernement
considère qu'il faut protéger la tva
parce que si on commence à absinthe
rouen réduire la raquette oui c'est ça
ça devient dangereux et on a ensuite des
actes d impôt redistributif tvn un seul
a pour quatre 24 4 % des impôts
la voilà on a un seul pour 10 e
proportionnelle son épouse aurait dit ok
l'impôt sur le revenu qui en france est
d'un montant très très faibles les plus
bas que la cgt qui a la particularité de
porter uniquement sur la moitié des
ménages / il est absurde de dire que y'a
que cette moitié qui payent des impôts
parce que les autres qui payent de la
tva de laquelle jette s'ils voulaient
les cotisations et la baisse des impôts
est possible quand vous avez une
croissance économique en fait c'est pas
le l'inversion des causes et des effets
est assez gênante parce que si vous
baissez ans dans une situation comme la
nôtre de croissance relativement faible
les impôts vous êtes déjà dans un
système de d'emprunt donc là vous avez
toute façon un budget des revenus de
l'état des administrations publiques
iran qui sont inférieures aux dépenses
donc si vous baissez les impôts déjà
vous augmentez la dette pour commencer
deuxièmement vous ne pouvez pas
augmenter baisser les impôts sans
baisser des dépenses donc ça vous allait
baisser des retraites c'est tout l'enjeu
de la réforme des retraites puisque
c'est bien à ça que ça sert la réforme
des retraites à points c'est baisser les
dépenses de retraite vous allez baisser
les cotisations sociales mais alors vous
allez baissé aussi les prestations
sociales etc
donc vous avez forcément je le répète un
impact sur le niveau de revenu et sur la
croissance économique
c'est ce que disait edouard philippe en
début d'émission pour baisser les impôts
il faut baisser les dépenses en examen
pas comme été relancé la machine est
fermé et rentabiliser les services
publics on en revient au service public
si cher aux français aujourd'hui le 25
avril 2010
lors de sa conférence de presse post
grand débat il y avait un grand débat
pour améliorer la situation
emmanuel macron avait promis notamment
de ne pas fermer d'école écoutez l'eau
et on en parle après nous devons sur ce
point remettre de la présence de service
public assuré l'accès aux services
publics à moins de trente minutes avec
un accompagnement personnalisé pour les
démarches de la vie quotidienne assurer
l'accès aux soins pour tous en luttant
contre les déserts médicaux ce qui est
au coeur du projet de santé qui est en
cours de discussion au parlement et ne
plus avoir d'ici à la fin du quinquennat
de nouvelles fermetures ni d'hôpitaux ni
d'école sans l'accord du maire voilà il
rejette évidemment la responsabilité de
la fermeture au maire il ya quand même
des écoles qui ont fermé non et non pas
seulement du fait des maires il ya ces
réseaux routiers ces réseaux
ferroviaires qui ne sont pas entretenues
pourquoi pourquoi montant d'argent pour
entretenir toutes ces infrastructures et
pourquoi ne peut-on pas garder une école
ouverte est ce que ça coûte très cher à
alain mathieu ont fait aussi les
investissements stupide tout à fait
inutile qu'on pourrait ne pas faire fois
mieux d'ailleurs d'entraidé
effectivement les voies ferrées en tout
cas celles qui sont cotées condition
d'utiliser parce que c'est des petites
lignes
oui à un train par jour ça mérite pas
qu'on l'entretienne il vaudrait mieux
mais des autocars à la place on apprend
enfin en tout cas inutile
je peux vous en citer un très grand
nombre vous avez le lion tural assez
faible tunnel si vos cils naturels utile
au tunnel sous la manche
au lieu de relier deux capitales lors
paris et londres qui ont 10 millions ou
12 millions d'habitants relie deux
villes de 1 million habitants c'est pas
du tout la même chose c'est totalement
inutile
prenez le canal seine nord me dit c'est
formidable on va voir un canal plus
grands ya déjà un canal
voilà bah il sera plus grand en réalité
ce qui va se passer c'est que des
marchandises qui passe sur le train
maintenant vous passez sur le canal ça
sert à rien c'est totalement inutile
prenons le cdg express
on a déjà une ligne de métro qui vas y
vas roissy on va en faire une autre
totalement tout ça on fait mais et et je
peux multiplier les exemples
on fait des investissements totalement
inutile
et voilà si on arrêtait ses
investissements inutiles on pourrait
faire des économies et peut-être
entretenir ce qui existe mais surtout je
pense que ce qui est important c'est de
bien voir ce qu'ont fait les pays qui
marche et pays développés comparables à
la france qui marchent à mieux que la
france et y en a elles un assez grand
nombre qu'ils ont fait ils ont tous
baissé leurs dépenses publiques
massivement tous je vais vous en citer
un autre certain nombre ce qu'ils ont
baissé de plus de 10 % de leur pib alors
l'irlande la suède le canada
tous ceux là ont baissé de plus de 10%
tous ces savoirs chez tous ces exemples
sont tout à fait et ce alors devenus
tous et a fait par exemple c'est tout à
fait ce groupe venu en force
on n'a pas le temps de voir dans le
détail mais il ya des cas vous comparez
ddd situation où effectivement il ya des
années où il ya des portiques très
importante parce qu'on a soutenu les bop
donc l'année donc ça permet de dire
effectivement et dépenses publiques ont
baissé dans d'autres cas il ya ces des
administrations qui ont été remplacés
par des agences privées
donc on dit ça a baissé mais en fait ça
ça lui le problème tourné dans plus de
ce challenge plus ne provoque plus de
deux ans ça marche pas mieux
regardez par exemple le gâche
épouvantable que représentent les
complémentaires santé corti qui
rembourse exactement dix fois moins que
la sécurité sociale avec des coûts de
fonctionnement totalement identique donc
effectivement il ya des économies à
faire
donc faut regarder y en a qui les ont
faites il ya des économies à faire le
complémentaire santé c'est un exemple
même de gâchis épouvantable on a on a
des des tas d'exemples le problème de
nos sociétés et c'est le problème qui a
été posé par les gilets jaunes c'est
qu'on a effectivement à la fois dans le
secteur public mais aussi dans le
secteur privé
énormément de gaspillage énormément de
gaspillage alors que les besoins
fondamentaux ne sont pas satisfaits le
jeudi il n'y a pas seulement le publie
y'a pas seulement public à tous les
dépenses de publicité tous les logos
hall l'obsolescence programmée
tout ça c'est des choses importantes il
ya les salaires exorbitants dédié des
hauts dirigeants du pli fait légale
pourquoi l ifrap ne s'en occupe jamais
guillaume îlots c'est à dire que ce qui
est complexe et que c'est vraiment un
si on s'intéresse aux dépenses publiques
de manière isolée c'est complexe parce
que c'est relié aux autres choix de
politique économique à partir du moment
où vous ne pouvez plus rien contrôler
vos frontières et vous avez des
phénomènes de délocalisation massive
vous êtes exposés à tous les vents de la
concurrence y compris que des pays qui
eux mêmes ont des barrières douanières
donc ça devient très compliqué à partir
vous ne contrôlez plus du tout votre
monnaie et que vous avez une monnaie
surévaluée par exemple qui va énormément
pesé sur votre compétitivité
ça va devenir extrêmement compliqué
aussi donc si vous voulez tout étant une
affaire de systèmes frotteront peut pas
isoler les dépenses publiques et dire
c'est très simple pour relancer la
croissance économique celui de baisser
les dépenses publiques ça marche
non c'est pas vrai c'est beau ça n'a
marché nulle part sarkozy ce pauvre
hollande
et ce pauvre va croquis effectivement
fait comme programme de réunions
massivement les dirigeants fait du toit
du bon pasteur des ports publics voir le
soleil gagnera pourquoi le combat
le site web est en cours je vais pas
répondre le seul moyen de sortir la tête
la tête aux deux c est faire c'est de
relancer la croissance économique c'est
lorsque vous avez de la croissance
économique
oui cela vous pouvez règlement des
comptes selon l'ars qui entend rester à
pau il chômage également on va passer
quand même à quelques réactions de leurs
deux internautes avant la fin de cette
émission
donc alors c'étaient les mesures
fiscales vont elles dans le bon sens on
a une réponse d'un internaute non
puisqu'elle favorise le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages de la classe moyenne
supérieure on en a parlé c'est vrai mais
il faut bien voir que ces deux en france
quand vous baisser les impôts et
notamment l'impôt sur le revenu et un
certain nombre d'impôts las forcément ça
favorise ceux qui payent des impôts
c'est à dire les plus riches et si vous
voulez favoriser les plus pauvres il
faut augmenter les prestations du signal
s'il ya un bien mariale si vous les deux
dates d'atténuer s'était fait que je
suis utile est ce que c'est efficace
surtout en mai le montant des dépenses
publiques il n'est pas fou qui pèsent
sur l'activité économique ça c'est vrai
en revanche si vous voulez atténuer
cette pression et baisser les impôts il
faut dans ce cas ne plus se soucier du
remboursement de la dette si vous faites
les deux en même temps
non vous n'êtes pas d'accord en il faut
pas baisser le montant de la dette on va
naturellement pas baisser la dette
actuellement il ya aucun problème on
réussit à de s'endetter à des taux
extrêmement monté avec l'entraînement
faible doc ccc mhedhbi d'un autre côté
naturellement pas l'augmenter de manière
démesurée
le problème le problème que nous que
nous avons c'est que il faut il ya
certaines dépenses publiques qui sont
indispensables d'autres auxquelles
effectivement on peut faire des
économies mais il faut faire ça avec
pertinence
quand on voit par exemple des agences ou
les directeurs ont des salaires fabuleux
on peut dire oui effectivement si un
domaine où on peut faire des économies
mais c'est le même problème dans le
c'est le même problème dans le dans le
secteur privé il ya ya un gâchis
phénoménal regarder le développement on
a le développeur le débat porte des
institutions financières ça a été un
gâchis phénoménal
on en reparlera on n'a plus le temps
malheureusement ce soir merci beaucoup
en tout cas d'être venu sur ce plateau
d'ayrté france pour débattre de cette
question des impôts qui préoccupe
particulièrement les français est resté
avec nous c'est là
de police mag l'info à suivre
je suis sur la voie de gandhi j'essaie
de le copier et même une mauvaise copie
comme noir a de la valeur je ne suis pas
là pour faire de quiconque un disciple
de gandhi je suis là pour trouver le
futur j'en dis